each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
good afternoon everyone it's a real
pleasure for me to be with you here
today I want to talk a little bit about
the work that my team is doing and since
we are in research we are looking a
little bit forward to what the future of
software engineering will look like and
there are many scenarios and I will show
you a few of them but whenever you
actually look into the future it's
always good to actually first look back
a little bit and so that's what I want
to do and the first thing that I want to
point out is that software engineering
is really a young science the first
software engineering conference was
actually 1968 it in Germany
garmisch-partenkirchen and was organized
by Friedrich Bower
a German professor which happens to be
my PhD advisor advisor
so in some sense I'm in the tradition it
turns out that at this first conference
on software engineering they did not
only define what software engineering is
but immediately they figured out oh we
have actually a crisis and maybe we have
that crisis today so one of the first
definitions of software engineering was
actually the following one it says
produce high-quality software with a
finite amount of resources to a
predictive schedule so this looks like a
definition that could actually be
applied to other areas as well so let's
simply replace software with automobile
when we would have automobile
engineering produce high-quality
automobiles or cars with a finite amount
of resources to predict its schedule
what does that tell us if this is the
definition of software engineering and
this is the definition of automobile
engineering it means that software
engineering is actually not so much
different right we deal with different
artifacts
but in some sense we have the same
problems as other engineering
disciplines too and so what I wanted to
show you today is actually but now and
then it's actually worthwhile to look
into other engineering disciplines and
see what is actually going on over there
to see is what can we actually learn for
software engineering so the three things
that I want to talk about is actually
what can we learn from other areas in
the first time it's I look into
analytics how are other areas using the
data that are actually collected during
the project process of producing
something and for software engineering I
will look into how do we can use some of
the data for what is called an S branch
analytics which is in some sense a
completely new area but will have the
most likely a big impact
the second area that I want to look at
is what happens in hardware so in
hardware former methods have been quite
successful
why haven't they actually been adopted
in software yet and so I'll show you one
example about equivalence checkers that
are used in hardware and now are also
making it into software and last not
least we are probably the most the field
where advances are most rapid so ten
years ago very few people had a cell
phone today lots of people have cell
phone twenty years ago there was no
internet today one third of the
population world's population is
connected to the Internet so what does
that actually mean if you build software
and how can we use these new platforms
ok so this is my agenda for today feel
free to interrupt me if you don't
understand and otherwise around and I
will also have a booth tomorrow where I
am happy to answer questions so let's go
into the first area analytics so if
you're looking to the business community
then the one of the most successful
books of 2010 was the book by Devonport
and Harris on analytics at work and so
what's
the observation the observation is that
in most industries they use in such as
the data in order to make better
predictions to make smarter decisions to
get to better results for example the
insurance come in distri the zoo they is
using statistics a lot in order to
determine how expensive will your life
insurance be depending on your health
record the financial industry is in some
sense making prediction models on how
the stock will behave so that they sell
or buy stock Healthcare prediction will
be made and whether you are very healthy
or whether you have a certain condition
and therefore should actually go earlier
to checkups so all these industries are
in some sense using lots of data to
optimize their processes it turns out
that when Devonport wrote this book
he didn't mention software engineering
and that's actually true because we as
engineers building software we rarely
use the data when we built a software to
optimize our process so before going how
we can use that data let me show you
something else that I thought was quite
insightful Devonport also present at
this table that says is if you have
certain data then you can look at did
you collect the data in the past and
then you simply report what happened is
the data current and maybe you can
already do an alert for example when the
stock exchange in the US crashed in May
2010 then suddenly certain stocks
dropped rapidly and so what the stock
exchange then introduces an alerting
mechanism then if if a certain stock
drops more than 10 percent in five
minutes then they stop the trading for
that stock so they just use real-time
data to make a decision what is actually
going on in software engineering do we
have an alert mechanism maybe it's not
good to continue on this path for
further development and so we were
looking to see whether we can build
tools that are actually alerting or
recommendation for software engineers so
the area that we want to apply this on
is branch analysis so if you build
windows or office you have hundreds
actually thousands of engineers working
at the same time on the same product and
so it's like building a concurrent
systems where you have lots of actors
that do something and for software
systems we know that we have to in some
sense make sure that they can work
independently so for big software system
for people use a similar mechanism so
you use a version control system where
you can actually create branches so you
take a snapshot of the certain system
and then everybody can work
independently and check in independently
has his changes but at a certain point
you have to merge this changes back
together because you ultimately you want
to build one system and so the good news
is about branching is it's really
isolates concurrent work so that people
can work independently of each other but
there's in some sense a cost involved
mainly you're not longer that agile not
everybody developer over here sees
actually the changes that are going on
over there and if they actually see
those changes too late Wow
you can't actually build the system
anymore because there are different
assumptions and and decisions that have
been made and so we call this code
velocities if you check in as an
individual developer then it's the time
of this check-in in his particular
branch until it reads them reaches the
main branch and so that other people can
depend on it
and so depending on product groups it
takes between two days that somebody
checks in and it's available to almost a
month that this is that the changes are
available elsewhere so that's really a
huge amount of time and so you want to
be more agile so can we actually
quantify how bad the situation currently
is and so here's just the visualization
of what goes on
these branching systems so this is a one
particular file somewhere in Microsoft
and the blue dots are actually changes
to that file but different people we'll
talk about that later so there are
probably thirty changes to that file
then the orange dots are all integration
so this particular file has to integrate
into this branch has to integrate into
that branch has to run promoted to over
there
and then only then oh there's this black
dot that means there was some collision
and so they had to undo something that
happened three weeks ago in a completely
different branch and so that's a bad
state of affair so we want to optimize
it but how can we actually optimize
working of people together what kind of
data can we use and so this is what's
known in the software engineering
community and empirical software
engineering they use quantitative and
qualitative measures so qualitative is
they ask actually the people that do all
these integrations what is actually your
problem why doesn't it work better but
then we also look at the data and we
mind the development data between of the
for the relationship between the teams
that are doing something and the
branches and then we can even simulate
if you figure out oh maybe there's a
better way to build the system we can
simulate how we would have build windows
in a better way and then based on this
insights we can build alert mechanisms
we can tell three weeks in advance that
there will be an merge conflict
later on because there are two people
working at the same time on the same
file we can build recommenders and so on
so this is what I want to do so three
slides very quick survey so we'll ask
people that goes wrong in building these
big systems for these branches and there
were more or less four major complaints
they call something like big bang merge
the manager decides oh now everything
has to get together and of course there
are lots of different things that come
together it never
you want to do it one by one slowly the
other part is there's development freeze
people want to have a stable snapshot
but that means that other people
shouldn't actually add stuff as you go
along so both of these actually are
managerial decisions sometimes we can't
really optimize those and better we
don't do those decisions but then there
are two things that we can optimize one
is called the integration wall that
simply means that people and the branch
structure somehow don't fit together and
therefore you can't there's always these
lots of these conflicts and the other
part is that because people are afraid
to change something that other people in
some sense that will break other people
they introduce more branches more
branches branches and so this is called
branch manya so we want to get rid of
those unnecessary branches so two things
we want to address
integration wall and branch manya
integration wall how can we figure out
whether the branch structure and the
people working on branches that they
that they fit together so we can simply
take a cross product of all branches and
then we say it's okay for if you'd now
take two of these branches what are
actually the files that are changed and
what are the people who are working on
those files and then we can build a heat
map and so here's a heat map for Windows
Vista and Windows 7 so the first
observation is that so there's on the
x-axis there's file similarity and on
the y-axis there's a developer
similarity so then you first observe
that the best part is actually most
branches should be at a place where
people that work on files and branches
if there are two different branches that
are really separate so that means that
they can work on in different people
work on independent files that's great
so most files should actually be there
then if the same developers work on
different files it's also okay
it's even okay if the same files in
different branches are worked on buying
the same people because they know in
some sense what goes on but what is
actually really bad is if there are the
same files that I worked on in different
branches by different people because
they don't know of each other and so if
the files that actually fall into this
red square they are a particular bed and
now you can see is how actually
organizational change impacts typically
also the behavior over time from Windows
Vista to Windows suddenly you suddenly
see that there are more files here where
there are different people working on
the same files so maybe this was not
such a great organizational change or
maybe it was a different branch
structure that was not optimal so you
really can track as how you organize
your work over time so then the question
is now from all those branches we know
now which branches are difficult but
which one should we actually take out
and and optimize a way and so one of the
ideas is since we have the whole history
with all the chickens for Windows we can
replay this history and take out
particular files and then check whether
we are actually a faster if these files
wouldn't be there and so we do this and
so we'll take out different different
branches and then we can observe that
there are certain files where in some
sense only at cost so they don't really
help with conflict avoidance but since
you also have to check in there first it
takes longer until this check in
actually reaches main and so all these
dots are actually particular branches
and the red dots the branches that are
red we can take them all away and
therefore have fewer branches and so
more agility in the system and so that's
actually what's currently going on and
so what's really interesting is you can
optimize processes by really looking at
the data that you are collecting in the
process one of those
it's branch analytics it really helps
with better design of a development
structure efficient scheduling and it
turns out if you actually have fewer
conflicts it also turns out that the
number of bucks that are released
afterwards are fewer so it even helps in
substance with pack avoidance so this
was analytics let's go to the hardware
industry and see what goes on over there
so in hardware industry there's one
thing that it's really made a big change
for them and this was in some sense
introducing formal methods and for
equivalence checking in hardware you
build socket designs and circuit designs
are boolean formulas and so what do what
two people want is to have one circuit
design and then they want to tweak it a
little bit and then still want to make
sure that in some sense the the tweak
design is exactly like the one that they
had before and so it really checks for
equivalence of circuits so since these
are all boolean formulas you can
actually represent them very compactly
in so-called binary decision diagrams or
as satisfiability formulas and there's a
technology for example for for checking
those such formulas that is probably
hundred thousand times faster today than
10 years ago due to advances in the
algorithms due to advances in hardware
and many other little places so in some
sense this area of checking of of
formulas has seen a really rapid
increase so it was actually very is very
successful in hardware there are several
companies that produce those tools when
they are used by Intel and and demons
and other big companies why didn't
actually that has happened for software
yet and the problem is that software is
more complex than hardware because we do
not only deal with boolean formulas we
deal with in some sense integers we deal
with a whole heap we deal with
concurrency we deal with abstraction
and so that makes it much more difficult
to do equivalence checking of software
but the good news is if we could do that
we don't have to write a specification
or for software because we have one
version and we can check is the next
version maybe the optimized version does
it still do the same and so that would
help with automatically solving these
merge conflicts for example because oh
maybe all the changes that this person
did was performance improvements for
memory improvements that it should still
be the same
so if you would have occurs checking for
software would be really cool the good
news is we are there so how does that
work so I said there's digital circuits
you translate into boolean formulas and
so what you actually do with programs
you translate them
also within formulas but formulas that
have then actually operations from
integers or or modular arithmetic in
them so here is a simple swap example so
there are two swap procedures they
should be the same the first one uses an
additional helper variable the second
one uses arithmetic to do the same thing
and doesn't use an additional memory
location so what do we do is we
translate this into formulas as we see
is there's always a single assignment to
one variable so we can actually defer
represent it as an equality and then we
name the output variables as well simply
swap one X for example so this is our
first translation here's our second
translation so now we have two formulas
oh we can actually talk to a theorem
prover and see whether they agree so
what are the property that we want to
check you want to check that your
outputs are the same but there's this
little tilde before that so actually we
don't check that they are the same we
check that they are not the same and why
is that lettuce has something to do with
this particular technology for
satisfiability checking we can now ask
this we give this formula to a theorem
prover and if this theorem prover says
it's unsatisfiable
means this we have double negation and
so then we know exactly all those two
problems are the same but if they are
not if they are satisfiable then we get
an assignment of values to these
variables that gives us a counter
example what went wrong and so that's
really the key how you can now check for
equivalents of programs of course as I
said programs have Heep programs have
also procedure calls so one thing is oh
if there are procedure calls we can
simply unfold the procedure so we simply
inline all the procedures the formulas
get bigger and bigger as a consequence
of the few improver can't handle them so
you need something smarter it turns out
that if you have a problem like this one
we have two methods for one and for two
and both called bar but it's the same
bar we know it's the same bar then we
can simply say so we replace this
instead of unfolding the definition of
bar in these two full minutes we can
simply take a symbolic representation of
this procedure that's called now f bar
and now we have something that works for
uninterpreted functions we have the
property that if the arguments are the
same then the results have to be the
same and so if the arguments to the two
bars are the same Wow then we can simply
take that as a result off of calling
those bars and so we use the following
trick here that we have this implication
and with this implication we don't have
to unfold the definition of the bar
method here we can simply represent this
power as an uninterpreted function and
so the program that we want to prove
equivalent does it does it grow in size
because we can represent those procedure
calls symbolically okay so what can you
do with equivalence checking so now we
have seen two programs that are
typically written in C sharp or C
and we can check us are actually the two
versions the same or are they is the
same model or some little change that we
made but we can also do something else
we can say is our two versions the same
that are that we have compiled in two
different languages for example we
compile c-sharp into microsoft
intermediate language and we can compile
c-sharp
also to x86 and now we can see is or or
which translate IL to x86 and now we can
see is these two programs still the same
and so this is what's known as
translation validation so the same
technique the cool is checking works
well for application compatibility
checking as well as translation checking
okay so we built a tool that's called a
zoom diff and the idea is it should work
exactly like a syntactic tool that only
looks at what what lines have changed
but it uses actually a sea improver
underneath and it uses some intermediate
representation which is called boogie
and so we built it in such a way that
you can actually take C or C++ a source
language or arm or net or x86 and the
way that it's built is like this so
there are the two Program Files that are
fed to zoom summative and then either it
says okay it's equivalent or it's not
equivalent and all the adaption to the
different source languages are actually
done outside of summative in the first
translation into an intermediate format
which is called boogie okay so let me
show you this in real life so I have a
little C program here and the first one
is actually an expression evaluator on
the left hand you see an expression and
it is actually P expression is an a
pointer to expression so it really lives
in the heap and we have the same
structure on the right hand side that
the evaluation procedure is written very
differently the evaluation procedure as
you see here uses a
some sense macros uses locals uses a
switch operation whereas the left-hand
side it's simply an if-then-else okay so
let's take some dip and see what happens
here's this tool we simply can run it
and what it does is actually it builds
in some sense a formula gives the
formula to the theorem prover checks
whether they are unsatisfiable and then
it it generates a trace if they are
different or it says most likely they
seem to be the same in this particular
case they are the same but there are
some caveats that's why it says they
appear to be partially equivalent okay
but this is good enough for us
so they are the same so let's do a
little change in our program so one
thing that we could do is for example
let's assume the next version of our
program had an additional multiplication
case in there and so we run assumed if
again and let's see what happens this
time this time it says oh I actually
generated a counter example for you and
this counter example we can inspect it's
in a trace so it's exactly the same
program left and right but now it does
something else it adds something in
these brackets so let me show you know
we have in some sense now new
information here so here he says he is
actually our pointer into the heap so
here it just assumed it's - 70 - 70 22
and the operation is 3 so it found
actually the fact that we have actually
added a multiplication so for the right
hand side we have exactly the same it's
the same heap it's the operation is
still 3 and then we execute since the
operation is 3 we fall through and we
actually get to that the expression is
still - 70 - 22 but the result is minus
1 in the first case but in the second
case the result is actually 0
and that's due to the fact that we
actually fell through this case and
actually we run into this multiplication
case and therefore that's actually where
our back now appeared because they don't
do exactly the same anymore okay with
this let me come back and see what
happened here so what happens is that
due to the fact that these tools are now
so these T approvers are so powerful you
can translate programs and to formulas
and then you can check all kinds of
properties for you can we will later see
how we actually use that for test case
generation you can use it for design
space exploration but here what simdiff
really does is actually it helps with
automatically deciding on whether
refactoring didn't introduce any
different new behavior it helps with
compiler translations so in fact
Microsoft uses the same technology to
verify that new compilers actually are
comparable with old compilers and you
can also do refinement checking so if
there if you fix it back then what you
allow in between the two programs is
that for the case where the old program
still has a back that the new program
has some new behavior it's not a bug but
every other place where program was
defined before should be defined
afterwards ourselves as well okay so
this was in some sense how you use logic
based tools for doing program analysis
let's move on to the next topic when the
next topic is what happens with our
platforms so one thing is that meanwhile
there are almost one third of all the
population is connected to the Internet
and it turns out that the browser is the
most widely widely used application that
we as educators we want to in some sense
also excite our students to use
to start programming and why can't we do
both so we can maybe use the Internet we
can probably lure people and because
people love to play so what does that
mean so we can actually develop we have
developed a tool that actually is used
by Microsoft and shipping for test case
generation but we don't use it for test
case generation we use it for solving
puzzles and so what's the puzzle I just
talked about equivalence checking is you
have a hidden program that you don't
know and the user writes a program that
should match exactly the same behavior
and if they are equivalent the user wins
and if they are not equivalent then the
user gets an advice on how to proceed so
let me show you this life so I hope it
works like so this is a PEX for fun and
the first observation is it's a real
website so go to this go to this website
thanks for fun calm and then oops you
can't see it so it's PEX for fun calm
and the way you can do everything that I
show you now you can do with me or maybe
a little bit later okay
so here's our first program it's a
simple puzzle and so currently it's
simply called the method puzzle takes an
integer returns an integer what can you
do
you can ask PEX execute this for me and
find be an interesting input for this
program so what's the what's the
interesting input so here the input is
oops is I is zero and as a consequence
the result is zero as well and so what
you get is in some sense these wonderful
tables that tell you something about the
the relationship between input and
output so that was not too surprising
but notice that it found some
interesting input
okay so let's let's make it a little bit
more interesting okay we'll ask if it's
if we returned one and of course now we
get slightly different input oops sorry
a slightly different input here that we
get zero as input and the output is 1
okay not too surprising let's do
something more interesting and say so if
we actually says which is one two three
four equal equal then we throw an arrow
and we say is o the system crashes okay
so let's see what happens now and so
what we should see is actually at least
two cases one where everything is fine
and now we get we get our error case
here where we get one two three four is
our infection so how far can we push
this this can be as I said arbitrary
complex formula so we can say is I times
three maybe plus seven then we still
find an input for this one and of course
now we ask the T improver give me
actually an assignment and oh it turns
out that the input for 409 409 dries
exactly the the execution into this
exception so that seems to be good so
but we really want to build puzzles so
how do we build puzzles we have to
define what what an assertion does so
let me introduce an assertion so we
introduce a public void static void
method that we simply call assert and so
it takes a boolean B and so what it does
is if if boolean does not hold then we
throw
and we saw and do it's section and now
we simply says assertion assertion
layout and so this one we say so let's
simply call this a certain method and
since we want to assert this we want to
make sure that we only passes if it's
not unequal and so we throw away this
guy and this is now our new program so
it should almost have the same effect
except that we called procedure here
that's our assert and C would be
actually in the system found how it
behaved still the same right but now we
can say it's now we have a nice
mechanism how we deal with assertions
now we can say okay let me introduce a
public int method that's actually the
hidden implementation and I and so what
the hidden implementation does is maybe
it just so returns it's the identity and
now let me introduce the user oops sorry
public user gets an end I and so what
the user probably has no clue initially
he just returns a constant and so what's
our assertion here our session is that
hidden hidden of I is equal to user I
right so we have to change this one to
avoid okay so now we have two methods
hidden and user and so let's see what
happens now if we ask PEX oh the method
must have a return type so maybe that's
not static int and it has to be static
here too
I was a compiler error okay and we see
oh the assertion has failed so now you
have seen that we can use these
assertions in order to compare these two
functions so what pecks now really is is
in some sense a mechanism in which you
can in which we have given and other
users have given you actually a programs
and there are hundreds of them in fact
there are more than hundred thousand
people that have used pecks so far and
so here's for example a challenge
arithmetic example so now this uses
exactly the same structure that I showed
you before but now you don't see the
hidden program anymore and you ask PEX
and pecks found one difference to our
program so let me scroll down a little
bit and now here you see oh it says with
my sorry if my with my input X is zero
then I also return 0 my own
implementation may be the the puzzle
function over there but the secret
implementation returned 0 as well so
that seems to be good but if I actually
look at the next case then we have a
mismatch and so I'll give so the system
gave a 1 as input I still return zero
because it's a constant but the secret
implementation returned -1 so if I want
to win this puzzle I have to match this
input-output pairs so I can be in some
sense brute force and many people start
exactly like this they says oh if I
actually have if my X is 1 then I return
then I return minus 1 ok so that seems
to do that oops sorry that seems to do
the trick so let's see what Peck says in
this case right that was we only saw two
entries but the system says is a little
bit small
says oh but if I give you actually a -
you still return zero but what I really
want to see is the - - so somehow this
adding these additional cases doesn't
really help and so anybody knows what to
write over here
what should I return over here - X okay
so let me introduce - X here and ask PEX
again and X is thinking and hopefully of
it tells you you have won the coding
duel yeah okay wonderful
so the funny thing is what we see as
example so it turns out that there are
500,000 people that have actually
answered puzzles so far in the last six
months so this exists only since six
months and we have seen very funny
solutions so here their typical solution
is actually X minus 2 times X and of
course we know that that's the same and
but now suddenly we see what problems
but people which programs they write and
so there are hundreds of challenges here
and there's also life feat let me see
whether there's a live feed where in
some sense you can actually figure out
who's actually currently using the
system for example server-side six try
to challenge the Caesar cipher and so on
ok so going back what did we actually
learn so one thing is is that you can
really excite people if you actually
make something again we didn't expect
that it would take off so nicely and the
way that you can really excite people is
if you actually build a social community
around it so there's this live feed
where they're also in some sense
champions this there's now also a
automatic cost work with automatic
grading in
in PEX for fun and what I think is most
exciting is that we go back to our
analytics because now we have 500,000
programs in our database that we can
know and we know what people wrote from
one version to the next until they solve
the problem or sometimes they didn't
solve the problem at all and we can see
as what's actually the thing that they
are stumbling over is it an abstraction
why didn't they actually make progress
more quickly so if you want to work on
this research feel free to contact us or
play with PEX for fun or at puzzles or
solve them the last topic so the
internet is great but I think what
happens even more rapidly than the
Internet is actually that cell phones
usage is outgrowing
even internet usage and so last quarter
of 2010 there were more smartphones
being sold including tablets than PCs so
desktops as well as laptops that these
guys Oh actually there is my eye these
are actually as powerful as pcs 10 years
ago and the new generation has already
dual-core and when we look back when I
started programming I started on a
Commodore 64 that had actually a much
fewer memory and this one if you think
about the processing power of this one
that's better than what booth used when
he developed tech for example or that's
better than what the UNIX was developed
on so the question is why can't we
program this one so forget about laptop
and PC and PC
can't we actually program the phone on
the phone so what would it need you need
help to rethink because this guy is so
small how do you actually enter your
programs how you debug it how do you run
it you want to make it easy discoverable
you want to use cloud services we have
seen the translator this morning
I want to use just a translation from
here the funny thing is the next thing
is as I said earlier I think sharing is
really important how if you develop on
this one how do we share the programs
with somebody else how do you share the
data with somebody else maybe on
Facebook how do you do if you want a
program a distributed system how do you
program distributed systems if you only
have a phone in your hand and how do we
do privacy and security so there are
lots of fun problems with this new
device and we've made some progress so a
month ago we release touch studio this
is a programming environment on this
device and so that changes everything
because this device is continuously
connected to the cloud and we'll write
some programs in a minute so that
changes in some sense what you do right
away it has lots of sensors with changes
in some sense makes this much more
attractive because you get GPS or you
get accelerators and you can yeah build
lots of fun stuff so for whom do we
think that this touch studio is we think
that professional people will still use
the big machines and the big screens but
there are many people like teenagers
like my son or my daughter who just want
to let's say have some fun and write
little programs there are millions of
people who write Excel or Word macros
they should be able to write and
personalize their phone so with this let
me get started and I want to see whether
we can program something together
something very simple on this device
okay so the first thing is I have to
login okay so here's that guy's okay so
touch studio is on the left
oh let me start this one and do you see
anything it's very probably difficult so
let me start coding so I click this
button and so I want to write a
completely new script
so what do we want to do is I said this
is continuously connected to the
internet so let's let me add a new
method let's call that simply go and so
what should this new method do it should
go to the web and actually collect the
pictures of cartegena so how can I write
this so I go and says I add something so
what do I want to do first is I
introduce a local so as you see this is
a structure editor where in some sense
you only see little fragments all the
time but then the keyboard is actually
very smart it knows to be what you want
to do so I said I want to do a web
search so I says ok I want to do a web
search there's a web button so I'll take
my web so when I wanted search for
images wonderful and I wanna see as let
me try to find images of this beautiful
city sorry
so typing is actually the most difficult
here cofirming is actually much easier
cartagena and that's what I typed here
so and so this is my first statement
result is a web search of images of
cartagena so then I'm done with this
line so then I says ok I want to add
something more what do I want I want to
print out all the images that are find
and so we can do that with a for each
loop and so for each no now no now snow
which local variables are in scope and
it offers me oh there are in some sense
the set of links that I actually
collected earlier in my web search so
I'm done so I go or for each overall
links and as a consequence it says ok my
local is now linked so then I'll say is
OK at one more line and what I want is
that for each link that I find for each
link that I find I want to post it to
the wall now wall is actually my display
on my device
and so this is all I had right so let's
run this program and see what happens so
we are searching Bing we are loading and
here are all the pictures from the web
and some are faster loading some are
slower loading here is another one and
you should actually recognize this
wonderful place okay so this was really
what did I enter I entered really three
lines in order to a web search for
images if you go and try to find a web
search on this device this is Bing as
you probably see Bing doesn't have
actually an image search on the mobile
phone so we just added some
functionality that is missing on this
device with three lights let me show you
something else and I want to go back so
it turns out that this smart phones we
have actually great graphics engines and
so what do most people do when they use
a smart phone they actually play games
with it
so let's write a little game and so
what's the mode that for most games what
they do is they do some physical
simulation so let's do a little physical
simulation and so in order to write a
game we write now a 2-d game or 2d game
where we actually want to have balls
bouncing up and down based on in some
sense of friction and we want to use the
accelerator so if I move my my phone
then I want to see that the balls in
some sense always jump to the place
where there's the biggest gravity so
here is the program then I don't program
it again but it's really this long is
probably difficult to see so what does
it do it maybe I'll show it explain it
it creates the ball that's in some sense
our physical environment our 2d and then
it has one loop where I create in some
sense balls ellipses and simply says how
how they elicit a elasticity
looks like and then I have another loop
where I look at the accelerator in this
device and depending on the accelerator
I move the bolts so let's see how that
looks like and here is in some sense the
whole program so I asked for 20 balls of
different size and it uses the
accelerator in order to determine for
therefore the in the physical world
where they should actually go and how
they in some sense should fly through
space and this is how most games are
done so actually 50 percent of all games
are not much bigger than 80 lines of
code if you have the right abstraction
so now since this is a wonderful device
I actually have also my media online my
device I cannot only take pictures from
the web but why don't I so here I just
had balls flying through the air I can
also say it so instead of taking a ball
I take a thumbnail of the pictures that
are on my phone and I let them rotate so
let me do that and so this is the
pictures and I think you get the picture
so the only thing that I've now changed
in this program is that instead of
creating ellipses I go to my media on my
device that's actually the pictures and
that takes some random pictures and now
I let do the same thing and I put a
different background in it and so the
whole program is this much so you see
everything let's see what funny pictures
I have here are my pictures on my phone
and you see that in some sense now I can
have my pictures floating around I could
go on and show you how you use Microsoft
translator and so on
everything that you can imagine is
typically as small as this one all the
programs are really simple it has an
integration into maps it has an
integration into OCR and what is really
the great news is since we are always
connected to the web we can use
all the functionality on the web for
example for speech translation we don't
have to do it on the phone we can send
the text over to the cloud and we just
get the translated text back so the
things I want to conclude and says
what's the the the I think the really
exciting things is that the cloud is
there and mobile is there and what you
really want to do is actually bring them
together and if you think about what's
the best programming environment maybe
programming on the phone is actually not
so bad but you have to change everything
your normal input mechanism with a
keyboard the suddenly replaced largely
with touch you have your programming
model suddenly changes very rapidly
because you have to in some sense get
very easy access to all the different
services they're there their cloud
integration it's it's a lot of fun but
there's also lots of danger because I
could actually send also my naked
pictures into the cloud and who knows
who sees them and who wants to see them
in the first place that's a different
story and of course you can imagine that
at programming on the phone and running
those scripts is actually a relatively
energy inefficient and so if you really
want to move that into mainstream you
have to think about how we make that
much more energy-efficient the good news
is you can try this out you can go to
the Windows Phone market store or to
this website and download it and so the
latest version I showed you one point to
one that has the graphics engine one
point one doesn't have the graphics
engine but it should come out every day
now so it's already registered this is
meanwhile number 38 of the most popular
apps on the Windows Phone somebody told
me if if we would have done it for
Android or iPhone I wouldn't have to be
here anymore
if I would ask for money for it but we
don't this is all free and it's it's
really a fun to use the device but also
fun to do
research for the cipa devices so summary
is I think everything that I talked to
you today is we have submitted papers no
paper has rejected yet so but it's so
fresh that I can't give you the links to
those papers but so software analytics I
think we really see that it will change
the software development process quite
rapidly and within Microsoft there's
more demand for it than we can handle
and it really enables making better
data-driven decisions the logic based
tools really help make better software
artifacts because you can check lots of
properties not only equivalences but I
will show you many more tomorrow if you
would come to the booth and I think as
whenever you you work in software
engineering is such a fascinating area
because it changes every year and the
cloud and the phone are really fun areas
and let me just mention one area that I
haven't talked about what about software
engineering and games so I showed you
some of the little games it turns out
that games is currently a 50 billion
dollar market there are almost no people
who so there are lots of people that
develop games but very few use software
engineering principles in this
development so there's a huge potential
in some sense to advance the game
development with the things that we have
learned in traditional software
engineering the best I want to conclude
I really want to thank you for listening
but also I have to thank all those
people these are people in my team and
oops and the one in the leftmost column
are actually the people which work I
presented over here but the others
helped in many many ways there are lots
of links thanks a lot for your attention
it was a pleasure to be here and have
the opportunity to talk to you
you